what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so I'm gonna go through make it
serious videos I'm like on my characters
in the MCU like too powerful for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe who would win
so on and so forth but in this video
we're gonna be goofy because I'm going
for diz I'm going Disney World like four
days so honestly I don't really care I
just want to kind of like goof off and
so we're gonna throw a Batman in the MCU
and just say like what would happen if
Batman were in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe now here's the cool thing about
Batman and Batman fans have to agree
because like it's true but like here's
the cool thing about that man is like
Batman can do whatever he needs to do at
any particular point in time to win
because the plot demands it but that's
the nature of Batman like his power is
pot armored like us that's the nature of
his character he's to power or he's too
popular to kill off okay here's a really
good example so in DC Comics you had an
event called Final Crisis which is a
descent into absolute madness like it is
basically a full-on tour of Grant
Morrison's brain no one understands
Final Crisis Grant Morrison doesn't he
understand Final Crisis and he's the one
who wrote it like it's it's one of the
weirdest is it's ridiculous anyway you
got this really called Darkseid who's
like this really really mean dude who
like literally rules over a planet that
might as well be hell and like he hits
Batman with the Omega sanction right
which is basically just like beams
energy whatever he hits Batman with
energy that would essentially like that
that can kill superheroes all right like
super-powered beings it can kill a human
it could easily vaporize and his
vaporized humans on more than one
occasion
it hits Batman he doesn't get vaporized
why because he's too popular to kill off
instead he just gets thrown back in time
and we actually had a prequel story
called like the return of Bruce Wayne
which is actually pretty cool it's like
the one great thing Grant Morrison's
done in 20 years aside from new x-men
but nonetheless it's interesting when
you when you when you look at that
because basically what it means is that
like Batman cannot die right so like we
know that if Batman gets thrown into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe he won't be
defeated because he's just too popular
to be defeated like it's like Deadpool
told Wolverine and Deadpool kills the
Marvel Universe your powers popularity
so with this whole thing in mind we're
basically gonna craft a story we're like
Batman wins right so basically Batman
would show up in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and just be like these Avengers
are too overpowered or whatever it is or
too underpowered like I'm pissed off
because the offenders are not like they
are in the comics so like every super
hardcore comic book fan ever they can't
differentiate between movies and comics
they're not without what I expected from
the comics like we're gonna get rid of
whatever it is he goes on a warpath
right so like the Avengers respond and
they're like what in the world is going
on here and Batman just like punches
Thor and then picks up his hammer now
people are gonna be like yeah but like
isn't about not supposed to be worthy it
doesn't matter
like Batman like this is the plot like
the
demands that therefore a Batman can do
it and so Batman picks up the hammer of
Thor and then just like starts swinging
and just crushes everybody and then
that's the end of the story that's
basically it that's why Batman is such a
weird character in comics but in all
reality if we were to look at this from
like a real and tangible perspective
right like we were we were to be serious
about this and we were to say Batman
gets thrown into the MCU and Batman
faces off again against the Avengers can
Batman win leaving out like the
convenience of pot armor basically
taking away like the entire argument of
Batman fans and we essentially like look
at Batman for what he is
yeah see well he could win against most
of them right like he could take out
star-lord he could take out rocket
racoon he could take out route maybe I
don't know like oh Allah he would be
great just like set him on fire like
there's any number of things that he
could do to take these guys out I mean
basically you're setting a tree on fire
or something like that or just hire
loggers to just cut route in half uh
anyway so so like characters like Iron
Man he could take out because I that's
kind of a funny thing if we were talking
about iron man with like the Indo Simson
I don't know probably not I mean at the
end of the day it is still a nanite suit
so it still does require like a
mechanical component and if it requires
a mechanical and electronic component
the bat may can still take it out using
like an EMP like a short-range EMP or
any number of tools at his disposal but
with a standard Iron Man suit where he
literally just puts on like an
electrical and mechanical suit yeah he
could be taken out by Batman Captain
America with the shield is gonna be a
little more difficult just because of
the fact that Captain America can punch
probably a little bit harder than Batman
can I don't know honestly I don't really
care enough to look it up but hehe but
we could say like they'd fight and bat
they will probably win because he knows
more martial arts styles because I mean
either that or he'll just say the head
would and just shoot Captain America
because well Batman doesn't normally
kill
um the plot demands it so we can so like
Batman just shoots Captain America then
you start getting into characters like
Thor in the Incredible Hulk and that's
really where Batman would fail because
in reality like I mean again we could
just kind of use the the Batman fan
convenience factor and just say well we
need him to do it so he can do it and
like Batman would just take the hammer
of Thor and just you know beat everybody
to death but if we're looking at it
realistically Batman would not be able
to defeat Thor or The Incredible Hulk
The Incredible Hulk she's too powerful I
mean sure we could look at like the
Marvel DC crossover from back in the day
and say like well Batman just like
kicked the Incredible Hulk and like
subdued him and like that was it and I
guess you could go with that you know
you can try to kind of take a bow if
we're gonna do the power scaling thing
then we have to get rid of things that
make it difficult for us to make an
argument so we can take that away and
say no no that doesn't really apply it
doesn't count because it makes it hard
for me to make my point and it gets in
the way of what I
I want to achieve so remove that out of
the picture and then just say like no
Batman cannot defeat The Incredible Hulk
because it's the Incredible Hulk his
strength is limitless even when Bruce
Banner just turns into the Incredible
Hulk and like his quote/unquote baseline
form
Batman would still get decimated that
would be crushed by Thor really people
like Hawkeye like Black Widow more or
less like your baseline humans would
find a way to defeat them now I guess
you'd find a way to defeat them now the
reason why I say Thor in the Incredible
Hulk is because they don't really have
any easily accessible weaknesses to
speak of I mean it'd be different a
Batman had like telepathy then he could
just like separate Bruce Banner the
Incredible Hulk
or like tricked Incredible Hulk into
space because he's basically an idiot I
mean if he was able to do things like
that sure but when you're talking about
characters whose power is literally just
brute strength and a healing factor then
they're not easily overcome I mean I'm
sure bad I could like construct a suit
or like improve on I mean you can see
him doing that like take out Tony Stark
incapacitate him and then like improve
on his Iron Man armors to make them
capable of like doing code toe-to-toe
with the Incredible Hulk and Thor
especially if he modifies the Hulkbuster
armor he could probably do that but
again like it's really just a crapshoot
I mean against throwing the Incredible
Hulk my answer my response is like no
it'd be kind of silly to believe
otherwise but I guess you know you could
find some kind of loophole or just chalk
it up to the plot and say yes sure he
could but nonetheless I mean it creates
an interesting scenario because for the
character of Batman I mean if you look
at him for what he is he's just a guy
who can like fight really well and he's
really smart and he's got gadgets and
stuff but using his intelligence and
putting it to task I think he would run
it I think he'd be stumped by Thor in
the Incredible Hulk the only way to
really defeat it would be to like get
them off planet and then like go from
there the only alternative to that that
I can think of is basically create like
brother I write like the satellite from
DC where Batman basically just like wolf
at least it became sentient later on and
then turned all the superheroes into
robots and the fur the futures and
storyline which technically doesn't
exist because it's just that bad but um
nonetheless like using those carrots
like using something like that like
converting them or word like taking over
their minds or like controlling them
using nanites or something on those
lines
honestly like it'd be kind of crazy to
see how Hollywood unfold I'd be curious
off the top my head
Captain America could probably be beat
by man by that man just by virtue of
using martial art styles and probably
pressure points or so on you know
something like that um black widow would
die or he would be defeated Hawkeye
would be defeated Ironman easily
defeated black panther would be
interesting because white Panthers
technology is so advanced and the suits
so cable delivering countless videos
about Batman versus
Panther so do whatever you want with it
I mean I would say our office about it
we're off the bat with the powers of the
Panther God
probably not I think Batman vs Eric
he'll monger would be a better fight
than like Batman versus Black Panther
especially Eric he'll monger in the MCU
I think they'd be a better fight um but
nonetheless like it'd be cool to see I
don't know I mean I kind of want to see
that fight go down like I kind of want
to see that that whole thing take place
I mean using his I mean using his
intelligence he could defeat a bunch of
those different guys he could take a
bunch of those guys out if we give him
prep time he could easily incapacitate
them but for someone like yeah for
people like Thor and Incredible Hulk I
don't think so I think he would
ultimately end up losing against them I
mean I can't really think of any okay
cuz here's the deal
back in the day and this doesn't apply
to the MCU anymore back in the day in
the comics if Thor was separated from
his hammer for 60 seconds he would turn
into Donald link he would turn into his
to his normal human form but Thor is
always in for mode so he's always like
super strong it's the one and so forth
it's just whether or not he can lift his
hammer here's a really good example so
like I imagine Batman could probably
commandeer the destroyer armor from from
like Asgard and then used that to take
out four and probably take out the
Incredible Hulk - to be honest I mean
again like the longer the Incredible
Hulk goes on fighting like the the
stronger he gets so eventually he would
just overpower the destroyer armor and
that would be the end of that but it's
not like fighting Superman right because
I Superman's got kryptonite it's all
Batman has to do is show up and he's be
like kryptonite Superman is like you
know like that's that's you know that
that's the end of that but like maybe
intriguing I mean I don't know I can't
think of any weaknesses on top of my
head because we've not really seen Bruce
Banner forced back into the incredible I
guess you know the incredible force back
into Bruce Banner form the only time
we've seen that is when he got when the
Incredible Hulk was wrecked so bad by
Thanos but he was scared to come out but
he was scared to manifest but like
Batman's not Thanos he's not nearly as
strong or as capable and so he wouldn't
be able to like he wouldn't be able to
BB Incredible Hulk to a pulp like that'd
be ridiculous like if that okay if we
got a movie where the inquit where
Batman beat the Incredible Hulk to
uphold people would laugh at the movie
and walk out and it would get like a two
percent on Rotten Tomatoes because we
will just be like that's ridiculous
because you know there was kind of be
like yeah I mean that's silly like I
love Batman and everything but like you
know but you know like that's not gonna
happen yeah hello I mean okay with he'll
bat okay okay so here's here's like I
see Batman doing that I could defeat
Black Panther he could in turn build a
held that armor but build a how about
armor out of vibranium and then in turn
used that to face off against Thor in
the Incredible Hulk and then he could
probably win I don't know like it's
whatever he's he's Batman like if he if
you want him to
and he'll win if you don't want to do
when he won't because like he can do
whatever you need him to do so like yeah
it's it's he's that man's clay he's
whatever the plot calls for like he's
litter the perfect superhero like he's
as weak as you want him to be he's as
strong as you want him to be he's
whatever you want him to be able to do
because you know like he literally lives
and dies by the plot he's in so you know
it's it's I don't know it's interesting
I'm kind of curious let me know you guys
thing down in the comments section but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come as explained make sure
you guys have the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
the video make sure you drop a like all
the Batman fans are gonna be pissed
don't care and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]